[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy nos preguntamos si la Unión
Europea ha perdido influencia en América
Latina y se ha perdido su oportunidad en
tejer mejores relaciones con la región
china le ha ganado la partida antes de
pasar al debate hacemos un breve repaso
sobre Qué tipo de relaciones se han
establecido entre China y América Latina
y el papel de la Unión Europea en la
región la comisión europea quiere
fortalecer lazos con América Latina la
presidenta de la institución Úrsula
vonderleyen anunció en su último
discurso del estado de la unión que era
momento de ratificar los acuerdos
comerciales con chile y México muy
especialmente porque ambos países son
productores de tierras raras muy
importantes para las energías renovables
el objetivo es depender menos de China
el mayor productor y exportador de
tierras raras del mundo pero el gigante
asiático Lleva años con una gran
influencia en América Latina con
inversiones y relaciones comerciales
ahora la Unión Europea quiere ocupar ese
espacio exportar los valores
democráticos en contraposición con
Beijing sin embargo los retrasos en los
acuerdos comerciales por ejemplo en el
caso del pacto con los países de
mercosur Hace temer algunos analistas
que la Unión Europea haya perdido la
partida también preocupa como en medio
de la guerra en Ucrania la propaganda
rusa ha ganado la partida en la región
aceptando las tesis sobre la seguridad
de Rusia y la amenaza de la otan al país
una tesis ampliamente extendida difícil
de contrarrestar y para analizar todas
estas cuestiones Contamos con nuestras
invitadas Inma Rodríguez Piñero del
grupo socialdemócrata bienvenida Inma
Bueno muy buenas noches gracias Y
también con la eurodiputada del grupo de
la izquierda Unión Europea y doy a
Villanueva bienvenida idoia qué tal
estás un placer estar aquí Muchísimas
gracias Igualmente bienvenidas las dos
ya casi veteranas en el programa me
gustaría empezar primero de todo con
Inma con una pregunta muy concreta es
china más influyente en América Latina
que la Unión Europea ahora mismo no yo
creo que china lo que sea ha conseguido
es aumentar el nivel de exportaciones
hacia latinoamérica y de sus
importaciones En ese sentido Es verdad
que ha pasado a ser el segundo socio
comercial de América Latina pero yo
estoy convencida que va a ser por poco
tiempo porque América Latina
es una región geográfica cuyos
gobernantes cuyos países cuya sociedad
civil comparte unos principios y valores
que son los de la Unión Europea en los
valores democráticos los valores de la
defensa de la libertad de la paz de los
Derechos Humanos no tiene nada que ver
con lo que representa China y
precisamente la respuesta de la Unión
Europea en ante la covid y la vacunación
y las donaciones
mucho los países de latinoamérica
demuestran dónde estamos yo creo que la
Unión Europea ha reaccionado se ha dado
cuenta de que no había hecho La Apuesta
por latinoamérica que se merece no
estaba en la agenda prioritaria de la
Unión Europea no es así el caso de
España Aunque para nosotros siempre ha
sido prioritaria Pero ha costado que en
la Unión Europea es verdad haya
conseguido situarse en la agenda
prioritaria y yo quiero recordar que en
el debate del estado de la unión
recientemente celebrado por fin la
presidenta underline la ha dicho muy
claro que es una prioridad de la agenda
política la reforzar nuestras relaciones
y lazos con latinoamérica así los
recogido también en su carta de
intenciones y en eso vamos a trabajar
para que realmente
nuestros socios que más falta hacen que
sean fiables que sean estables tengan
todo la capacidad de influir con
nosotros y que nosotros con ellos
justamente después de estas palabras de
uso la Fuente vamos a hablar pero antes
estás de acuerdo crees que ha perdido
influencia la Unión Europea en América
Latina Bueno yo creo que precisamente no
las palabras de wonderline diciendo
necesitamos reforzar la relación con
América Latina da unas claves sobre la
situación actual y yo me gustaría antes
de abordar precisamente esa relaciones
entre los países y los continentes
señalar que actualmente lo que estamos
viviendo es ya llega un momento del
colapso del sistema que no puede seguir
creciendo al mismo ritmo que iba
creciendo por lo tanto ahora mismo se
recrudecen algunos conflictos y empiezan
a ver nuevas relaciones internacionales
para
disputar quién va a ser quien más va a
crecer y quién va en contra a tener
mayor de crecimiento y en ese sentido se
reconfiguran muchas relaciones
internacionales china obviamente
ha tenido más influencia en América
Latina en los últimos años también en
otras partes del mundo no y tiene forma
de relacionarse diferente por ejemplo en
América Latina ha utilizado capital
político económico diplomático pero
también se ha acercado a los países a
veces comprando deuda como puede ser el
caso de chile y la Unión Europea en los
últimos años ha basado las relaciones
con América Latina fundamentalmente en
acuerdos económicos no en acuerdos
económicos que muchas veces se perciben
también desde América Latina como
asimétricos no en este sentido yo creo
que estamos en una nueva era en una
nueva oportunidad y que la Unión Europea
tiene que ahondar por por
sí misma en esas relaciones de
cooperación pero revisando que hemos
hecho hasta ahora bien y que es
mejorable en esas relaciones y que no
terminen siendo solo puramente como digo
acuerdos económicos muchas veces
asimétricos sino que se trabaje en una
cooperación con mirada mucho más larga
con un continente que es esencial para
el desarrollo también de nuestros países
yo y es una matización porque estoy de
acuerdo con lo que has dicho pero hay
una cosa que no es del todo cierto
porque los acuerdos que tiene la Unión
Europea con América Latina Son acuerdos
de asociación que incluye un Pilar
político un Pilar de cooperación y el
pilar comercial porque realmente la
cooperación es fundamental No yo lo que
creo que en lo que falla la Unión
Europea es que tenemos demasiados
instrumentos de cooperación muy
dispersos Yo creo que es fundamental y
más de mil instrumentos de cooperación
que están funcionando en la técnica en
Latinoamérica hace falta concentrar y
reforzar esfuerzos y centrarse bien en
dónde son las principales necesidades de
cooperación porque han de ir de la mano
cooperación y comercio para que el
comercio sea un comercio justo y esté
efectivamente equilibrado no
en este sentido yo creo que lo que
necesitamos es Escuchar precisamente a
los países de América Latina más no y no
solo a los gobiernos sino a la sociedad
civil organizada no
yo creo que sí que hay una conclusión
Clara y es que el tipo de acuerdos
comerciales que han existido han ido a
reforzar mucho el poder multinacional
muchas veces y en gobiernos que han
tenido políticas bastante liberales en
los países no por eso hay muchas veces
que la sociedad de América Latina ha
percibido estos acuerdos de la Unión
Europea como contrarios a los intereses
propios no de sus de su ciudadanía por
tanto yo creo que ahí hay una reflexión
que hacer también para saber cómo
mejorar esa cooperación Y esa esa
alianzas comerciales y desde luego tiene
que pasar también por bueno hacernos
responsables también sobre esos acuerdos
sobre las actuaciones que tienen las
empresas en América Latina sobre avanzar
en leyes de de vida diligencia de
respeto al derechos humanos pero también
a los derechos ambientales a los
derechos de las poblaciones y como digo
creo que ahora se abre una oportunidad
para Honestamente trabajar y afianzar
ese tipo de relaciones
hacía referencia a las palabras de uso
Lander Legend en el discurso del estado
de la unión habló de ratificar cuanto
antes los acuerdos con México con chile
y que aún falta su modernización no hizo
mención alguna a mercosur que es lo que
ha ocurrido ha faltado visión
estratégica ahora de repente se ha dado
cuenta la Unión Europea que está yendo
hacia atrás Bueno yo creo que hay que
situarlo en el contexto temporal porque
ya habló claramente de reforzar las
relaciones con latinoamérica y de que
prioridad en la agenda política lo que
ocurre es que a muy corto plazo sí que
están ya muy cercano a la al trámite
final la modernización de los acuerdos
con México y con chile mercosur requiere
todavía mucho recorrido y efectivamente
tenemos que esperar lo primero al
resultado de las elecciones en Brasil no
Entonces nosotros necesitamos socios
fiables México chile son socios fiables
la modernización del acuerdo era
imprescindible insisto es un acuerdo de
asociación de cooperación política y
además se refuerza el capítulo
desarrollo sostenible donde están esos
elementos tan importantes para ayudar a
que nuestros Socios conjuntamente con la
Unión Europea porque no se trata de dar
lecciones a nadie se trata de acordar
cómo queremos que se produzcan los
bienes y servicios que comerciamos no
vale todo no vale que se produzcan
bienes y servicios con explotación con
trabajo forzoso con explotación infantil
por eso es tan importante la diligencia
de vida Que tú hacías referencia y algo
que a mí me parece fundamental que es la
prohibición de importar productos que
hayan sido realizados con trabajo
forzoso y eso va a equilibrar nuestras
relaciones con China y si esto lo
trabajamos conjuntamente lo acordamos
con latinoamérica también la influencia
de china en Latinoamérica disminuirá
porque el avance de china en
Latinoamérica Se ha producido con
gobiernos de extrema derecha o gobiernos
ultraliberales qué ahora se dan cuenta
de que ese no es el modelo de desarrollo
que la Unión Europea somos un confiable
porque Trabajamos conjuntamente para
ayudarles a reforzar su capacidad de
crecimiento y desde luego es fundamental
la involucración de la sociedad civil
por eso los grupos de asesoramiento
nacional es una de las tareas
prioritarias en donde trabaja la
comisión europea para reforzarles Y
darles la capacidad de poder influir en
sus países en sus gobiernos para ayudar
a mejorar las relaciones de todos no
Inma hacía referencia a las próximas
elecciones de Brasil hemos visto cambios
en Colombia con la elección de Gustavo
Petro también con Gabriel borich en
Chile veremos que puede pasar si
finalmente Lula da Silva podría ganar
las elecciones estos cambios pueden
favorecer más a mejorar las relaciones
con la Unión Europea después de
relaciones un poco tensas Bueno yo creo
que se pueden dar en unos términos algo
diferentes no O sea América Latina lleva
en su historia también varias cicatrices
sobre de injerencia extranjera no en
América Latina hemos visto cómo incluso
desde Estados Unidos se ha apoyado a lo
largo de los años cierta parte de golpes
de estado en algunos de los países y sin
embargo cómo está viviendo ahora un
ciclo de movilización social de
recuperación democrática y de nuevos
gobiernos progresistas en la región no
en este sentido y frente a los retos que
tenemos globales y para los que es
necesario esa cooperación para trabajar
contra el cambio climático para hacer
nuestra vida más sostenible para
trabajar por la transición energética
por la soberanía alimentaria necesitamos
llegar a acuerdos de cooperación
beneficiosos para ambos pueblos pero
también como decía respetando y dejando
de ver algunos de los continentes solo
como fuentes de recursos específicos no
wonderlayen también en su discurso
hablaba de México de chile en su momento
como de lugares estratégicos de materias
creo que en los cambios de los gobiernos
que se dan en América Latina no es una
cuestión de que vayan a mejorar sino a
potenciar las relaciones de una manera
diferente y creo que es una oportunidad
y creo que que la Unión Europea debe
estar abierta y escuchar a esos cambios
que está dando la sociedad civil en
América Latina pues para mejorar esas
relaciones de cooperación beneficiosa
para ambos pueblos pues Lamentablemente
nos hemos quedado sin tiempo Gracias
Inma idoia ustedes les esperamos en el
próximo programa de Europa hoy Gracias
por ver France 24 en español
[Música]